Please tell me you've got a plan
i don't know how we win this one
killing her is the only thing
that's going to keep us all safe
stupid boy i'm going to have to kill
you too she keeps getting more powerful
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new video for the flash's first look at bart
allen we have to talk about what they did here
with this i know there's a lot of big questions
about what's going on with the flash most people
kind of tuned out after a crisis on infinite earth
so i will catch everyone up and explain what's
going on with bart allen on the tv show but if
you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos there is a bunch of really cool
stuff happening this summer i have not been very
happy with what they've been doing with the flash
so i haven't been doing episode videos for the
season seven episodes so far like i didn't enjoy
the mirror master storyline and i really didn't
like what they were doing with the forces from
the comic books but you all probably saw that the
flash released their official first look at their
version of bart allen that they're introducing
on the show during the 150th episode if you do
not like doing math that's actually going to
be episode 17 later this summer episode 11
is next week as of me posting this video i believe
the idea is that he will eventually become a
bigger character on the show in the same way that
when they introduced the nora character she went
on to be a big character that season the actor's
name is jordan fisher you may recognize him from
some other tv shows he's been in a bunch of stuff
he's also a musician so he's also been posting a
lot of music videos of himself too the actor seems
like a totally nice dude but we have to talk about
how they did him dirty with this bad photoshop
picture for example this is what he actually looks
like without any special effects he posted this
picture of himself in the costume and it looks
way better than the official photoshop they
released but clearly they're trying to do
a version of this iconic bart allen comic
book pose with him running into the frame
there have been several photographers on the set
that have gotten way better previews though of
what he's actually going to look like during the
episode they've been filming his episode and you
can see there are several versions of godspeed
onset so it sounds like bart allen's storyline
on the show is connected to the new godspeed story
arc with the real version of godspeed that they
teased a while ago the costume is obviously just
based on his original comic book costume when he
debuted in the 90s they made a few major changes
to his backstory that you've probably heard about
most of you have either read some version of bart
allen's comic book stories the classic ones from
the 90s when he was first introduced or the more
recent ones or you've watched the young justice tv
show for those of you that are big young justice
fans they're actually in the middle of finishing
the young justice season 4 episodes those
are going to release on hbo max at some point
either later this year or next year sometime
they don't have an official release date yet
what they've changed about this new live-action
version of bart allen though is that on the flash
tv show he's going to be barry allen's son in
nora's twin brother instead of being barry's
grandson like he was in the comics so you can see
that they're finally trying to pay off barry and
iris's twins from the comics everybody remembers
back to season four we're gonna need more diapers
oh they finally going to pay that off a couple
years ago when we heard that pretty much everybody
was thinking that they were trying to tease
barry's twins from the comics but then they
introduced nora and everything was way different
i think they didn't want to use crisis on infinite
earths to change nora's backstory that much and
change her name so they wanted to keep nora but
they also wanted to do the twin storyline so they
just decided to do like the next most popular
character as part of the flash family who was
bart allen if you watched smallville back in the
day they did their version of the flash but they
did him as bart allen instead of calling him barry
allen so before the flash changed everything a
whole bunch smallville changed everything a whole
bunch i know there are a lot of questions what's
going on with nora because the last time we saw
her was before crisis on infinite earth and she
sacrificed herself to help defeat reverse flash
but in doing so erased her timeline from existence
thus erasing herself from existence in the last
time that we actually saw a version of her on the
show it was when barry was seeing a vision of a
potential future version of baby nora leading up
to crisis so as part of this 150th episode they
are also bringing back nora and she's going to be
around for a couple episodes i'm assuming because
they rebooted everything with crisis this is going
to be a completely different version of nora with
a different timeline where they did actually have
twins bart allen was the son of barry's son dawn
who married melanie thawne the reverse flash's
ancestor from the 30th century reverse flash is
from the 25th century so bart allen is hundreds of
years removed from him but he's like a great great
great great great great grandson and as you would
expect reverse flash hates the mere thought of
his existence but what happened in the comics is
that reverse flash in the future has barry's twins
killed after bart was born but then bart is taken
into custody because he has speed force powers
experimented on by scientists until he's rescued
by a version of iris west who brings him back to
present day because in the comics iris west is
a time traveler but in present day because wally
west is the main version of the flash and barry
is still dead and trapped in the speed force wally
west becomes his mentor and bart allen becomes the
new version of kid flash but in the last couple of
years bendis just brought bart allen back to be in
his young justice comic book which is completely
different from the story of the young justice
tv show so because the bart allen and nora allen
twins storyline on the tv show seems like it's
connected to the godspeed storyline that they're
setting up now it sounds like they're going to
try and do some of bart's original comic book
backstory mixed with the classic twins storyline
in a couple of other godspeed related stories
they've been doing the different forces from the
comics for the past several episodes i haven't
been a huge fan of what they've done with that
godspeed does show up during a version of that
in the comics but the way they explain the forces
in the comics in the storyline on the tv show are
completely different the force's storyline in the
comics was a big hunter zolomon zoom storyline
mina also shows up during that storyline as well
they kind of tease mina at the beginning of season
seven but we haven't actually seen her character
yet but just because tom cavanaugh and cisco are
leaving the show doesn't mean that they'll never
come back they're just leaving as serious regulars
they'll probably come back in cameo every once
in a while so i know the next question is what's
happening with that whole reverse flash speed
force ghost storyline is that still going to
wind up turning into a red death storyline or
are they going to do something else with that
because they still have not answered that question
the last time we saw him his negative speed force
essence just arched off into the sky in search for
another body to possess and that was the end of
it my assumption is that because tom cavanaugh is
leaving as a series regular they'll just use that
storyline to introduce a new version of reverse
flash personally i would prefer that they just
use red death for that and if they want to recast
a different actor they can just do the same thing
that they did with zoom at the beginning of
season 2. remember how that worked they put him
in a comic book helmet like a full face mask they
had somebody else do the voice until later in the
season when they wanted to reveal who he was until
they cast the actor they've kind of been doing a
version of that with godspeed so far just waiting
to reveal what the actual real godspeed looks like
like all these other versions are just clones and
the real one will eventually show up and they'll
cast some other actor to play him at the pace
they're going though it seems like godspeed is
supposed to be the final main villain of flash
season 7. if you're confused about what's going
on with the flash forces they're all over the
map with this it has not been good on the show
they're not doing all the comic book forces and
even in the comics they upgraded the concept of
the original flash forces with more recent stories
but in the comics it started with the speed force
the negative speed force the still force the
sage force the strength force and the forever
force there are all these cosmic forces that
were unwittingly released when barry and wally
west broke this cosmic barrier that was holding
them at bay in zoom hunter zolomon was seeking to
control all the forces himself making himself
all-powerful later in the comics they sort of
upgraded this concept to the cosmic forces and
they revealed that there are seven hidden cosmic
forces of creation the legion of doom goes on this
quest to try and control them but the tv show is
probably never going to do that version of the
story so you don't really need to worry about that
but so far they're only doing the speed force the
sage force the still force and the strength force
and like i said they're going to wrap that story
line up i think either by episode 11 or episode
12 it might be episode 12. what they explained was
that barry inadvertently killed the original speed
force himself by poisoning it with spectre energy
from crisis on infant earth like oliver's spectre
energy and when they eventually did create this
version of the speed force which is apparently
evil in trying to kill barry now i'll get to
that in a second they explained that iris west
helped him create the new speed force because she
had a spark of the original speed force in her
from way back at the beginning of the pilot
episode she came to visit him while he was in his
original coma at the beginning of the show there
was a small portion of speed force that entered
her body and that's how they kind of explain her
being his speed force tether this sort of tethers
him back to this reality so the two of them
wind up creating this new artificial speed force
but also creating the other forces inadvertently
when that happens which is why they're calling
the other forces barry's children which is
totally ridiculous but i think they're using
that idea to sort of foreshadow the eventual
reveal of their real children which we'll see
later this season so you got four kids two of
which are so pissed off they want to kill you
this is why some people shouldn't have children
don't feel bad if you've fallen off the flash it's
been completely ridiculous what i'll probably wind
up doing is i'll do a video for the 150th episode
because that is a big deal bart allen pretty big
character then maybe a video for the godspeed
episode when they finally reveal the official
version of godspeed maybe like the finale but i'm
probably not going to be doing weekly videos just
because the quality on the show has dipped so far
there will be some really big budget quality dc
shows coming but those are going to be the hbo max
spin-offs from the movies so for instance matt
reeves is doing a batman hbo series spin-off
from his batman movie with robert pattinson james
gunn is doing a suicide squad hbo series with john
cena's peacemaker character those episodes are
actually going to be the first ones that we'll
see those will drop in january there's also the
green lantern hbo series i'll be doing videos for
all those series when they premiere next year
the next real big thing that's happening is i'll
be doing the marvel loki episodes on disney
plus that's going to start in a couple weeks
so make sure you have alerts enabled for
my channel so you don't miss any of those
if you do have any big questions about what's
going on with those dc hbo series or the upcoming
dc movies just leave them in the comments below
but everyone click here for my brand new loki
trailer in episode 1 opening scene and click here
for my brand new shangshi trailer and easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!